[Music]
all right do you guys know what the word
anthropomorphic
means oh i used to know this one it
sounds like a lens or something
oh it does that's like the measurement
of
no is it is it historical [ __ ] no
oh i know this is me too i know this
word anthro
is like a society right like yes society
or sure
meaning for everyone moving animorphs
the way that society moves
kind of so it's uh it's and people that
turn into animals
uh no kind of it's animals that turn
into people
oh yeah if we were doing trivia right
now i'd be like yeah yeah let's write it
up
right now right now is it the way
society
changes together people that turn into
animals
yeah is it mighty morphin power rangers
yeah like
transformers yeah there it is boom yeah
people turning into vehicles
yeah yeah vehicles like i recently read
this word
yeah okay all right what people have sex
with vehicles you guys are hovering over
the meaning
uh pretty well so don't tell me just
kidding tell me anthro
is basically people right yeah and so
anthropology is the study of the people
it's a more crazy story yeah i was there
yesterday i was i had to pick up some
plates yesterday yeah
very expensive but very nice so i got 50
i got f so far yeah
and then the morphic part right you're
talking about people
turning into things like a log into a
mushroom anthropomorphic is what people
do homomorphic
anthropomorphic oh there's what we do to
say i like anthropography when we have
sentimental value towards say
uh a piece of clothing we have to throw
it out you're like oh
this is sure we human feelings to
objects like cartoons cartoons
animals and you personified them as
human traits
that's anthropomorphic oh yes
we do that like that movie we do that to
everything
every child a kid a car kids [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] with cubs to be like
this cup is dancing are you spying on me
yeah i do that too i'm putting away the
dishes i'm like
you love going home i'm cute
that's [ __ ] cute
now if you had to apply anthropomorphic
things to uh traits to poop
what would you assign poop to to be like
what [ __ ] a pirate i don't know a
[ __ ] bart's like a yeah
pirate i had a neighbor's diaper
goodbye my neighbor said bye she would
go like i had to go to the bathroom and
then like her parents
you hear i'm done and then she goes bye
isn't there a south park character
yeah mr hanky yeah he says bye does poop
all the time
and then you put them in your mouth well
that's the part of the song you put them
in your mouth yeah
you don't want to poop put poop in your
mouth don't poke don't put people in
your mouth
i'm asking you guys what uh poop what's
the personified version of what
poop would be like i've never thought
about that and it makes me weird
actually it makes me feel weird like and
i'm uncomfortable with something that
was in my body being professional
unless it was a baby oh well if we're
gonna personify some other [ __ ] too i
guess a baby
a baby oh you would your turd would be
like i gave birth to it
yeah you see that i created it i gave
birth to it
a butt baby yeah so yeah i'll say butt
baby as well a butt baby that means i
always give birth to like triplets and
more last night you gave like you know
it's never one at a time you know like
lane has a channel called three and me
there's always at least he takes a
picture of his poop and he puts on his
instagram yeah that's all right the
reason why we're talking about animating
poop is go plus
all right so there's a new japanese app
called
encore all right let me get one all
right
this is something you know bizarre [ __ ]
why why i wanna know it
encore you know that word or it's like
again
right i don't know if it's a play on
words but uncle
is [ __ ] in japanese yes uncles so uncle
yeah it's spelled u-n-k-o like flint
phonetically or whatever it means poop
and then cor or maybe it's
i don't know that's how you would say it
if it's u-n-k-o-r-e
it would be okay then it's and it's uh
koi means uh collection so this game oh
because it's short for collection
because what they'll do is they'll get a
word like collection and then they'll be
like call it
like they'll shorten it so we're
collecting [ __ ]
yes it's [ __ ] collection so this game
was developed
or it's an app really but they're really
kind of you're trying like pokemon go
kind of
yeah yes exactly so with your [ __ ]
man dude sign me up how do you trade you
don't well you don't trade in a person
hopefully if i basically trade anything
with this this is all your [ __ ]
information i'm not the biggest
collection dude
my dietitian went live how do you play
uh
so it's not necessarily a game but it's
kind of masked
as the game so it's it's a project
launched by a gastrointestinal surgeon
exactly cool gastroenterologist or like
a dietitian that specializes in
in gut they're so interested in poop i
swear they're trying to collect data and
they're trying to make it fun right now
yeah
they're trying to be like oh you guys
should study your own [ __ ] how to make
it fun for me she wanted me to
create a um because i was showing her
how i i made stickers
and she wanted me to make poop stickers
for her so she could use them all cute
did you i know i told her i was too busy
but i would have interesting so in this
game
you you take your [ __ ] and basically you
document what your [ __ ] is like
and then the goal of the game or this
app is to teach players
about life-saving digestive health
measures
such as intestinal bacteria so like you
need to know about intestinal bacteria
so in order to be more interested in
intestinal bacteria they
applied some human traits to them and
within the game and they come in the
form of attractive
anime girls wow my girls
yeah yeah why can't they be little
animals yeah this is hella weird
a little brown animal this is kind of
like the artwork of
a gastrointestinal gain i prefer to poke
bones
yeah so maybe you do collect and maybe
you're trying to collect all the girls
you're trying to collect all the
intestinal bacteria you need to have
different types of diseases for you to
have some of them
villains like constipation you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna like i'm gonna pull
a part
that's one too many waters i have no
idea how to what's the scale
you know like what's the rating system
what's green a green one
[Laughter]
bam so is that the poop color
collecting cards or something i haven't
had no idea how this is
white poop oh that's a thing i read
about that before i got white poop one
time
you did yeah when i had a really bad
stomach flu for like three days all i
ate was bananas and crackers and water
and it was white and it was a white poop
it was crazy whoa
there was a phase in the summer when i
was where i was eating like whole
watermelons in a day
and my poo watermelon yeah i get that oh
yeah i like
like half a metal grapefruit does that
too and blueberries make it blue
yeah beets what was your poop watery no
it was red
red really really oh [ __ ] yeah beets
i've had beef
beets are scary beets look like blood
yeah it looks like you're gonna die
mine what mine was like it was like a
bright red like look like strawberries
you know
and sometimes the fiber's in there too
see my guy bar he knows
i like watermelon yeah so what do you
guys think uh
an appropriate anthropomorphic take on
intestinal bacteria i mean i don't think
it's sexual it's not hentai
i just don't understand the scale but
it's not close enough
pretty sexual all about all of the
mangas like that
and like it's like why they have to make
them people why can't they make commands
oh yeah like where's the dudes in this
game no there's not japanese games i
mean it's kind of like
sailor moon's all women but it's not
sexual yeah that's true
yes it is sailor moon is not sexual i
don't know sailor moon's not coming on
my body
i had the hardest dick in elementary
school though
[Laughter]
i don't know we gotta re-watch sailor
moon because there was things that we
probably didn't pick up as
like we were kids you know oh yeah
anime is pretty just in general even
kids anime like dragon ball
yeah like if you see the japanese
version you know i don't think the giant
breasts are popping up yeah and then
like
goku is like looking at her but yeah
he's like a little perv yeah yeah yeah
jake is hanging out and [ __ ] what and
that's a cartoon for kids
it's awkward it was awkward watching it
as an adult yeah we recently watched
dragon ball dragon ball the first
episode of dragon ball z
yeah the nosebleeds and everything yeah
he gets nosebleeds from looking at
[ __ ] ass cheeks or what oh that's how
i get mine
this guy's always got those leads oh
[ __ ] dude
he's always training with guys though
when he gets nosy he's so funny
beautiful dudes around man he's just the
plumpy cheeks
right like someone's so perverted they
get a nosebleed
true is that does that actually happen
though i don't know but it's quickly
enough for comment below if that happens
to you
that is not that's not a real thing i i
mean i'm sure
it's like a thing in japan not that
people i've seen people do it but it's
like a way to describe
like oh that guy's a part like he's
perving so hard that he's bleeding like
it's in a metaphorical thing where it's
like oh there he that guy's got blood
rushing to his head
yeah yeah yeah maybe he burst in a blood
vessel or something
but okay he's still rushing to his day
the only thing i see about this is that
like if your poop is healthy you're
getting the same character every time
you're like
michelle again damn it true so they
they're imploring you to explore
unhealthy yeah that's what i was saying
i was like so you have to get diarrhea
to collect it you have to somehow figure
out how to get green poop
and white poop yeah how do you play is
my question you eat tacos in the morning
[ __ ] you take it you take a picture i
don't it doesn't say take a picture but
it says to document your
your poop so they might after 10 days
you get another character
or something true yeah what if they tied
it to like a game like league of legends
or something and it's like to
unlock a character you have to you have
to take a picture of your [ __ ]
yeah that would actually make research
pretty good because like
if they need data yeah you need people
to come join
yeah you know most of the time i don't
even see my own [ __ ] because i wipe as
i'm still sitting and i let go
you never look and then by the time i
stand up and flush the
toilet paper covers it oh you never look
no
i always i wipe and i always take a look
and then i and then i cover it yeah wait
so you wipe
and you're holding the wife so there's
[ __ ]
there i go like this i wipe it out and
then i fold it and then i blow my nose
[Laughter]
yo you know you're joking with that
did you take a bite of your burrito and
then you [ __ ] dab your mouth
he's still eating on the toilet corners
of his mouth
the paper towel dispenser really no you
know i will say this
bart's house is the most one of the most
comfortable places to poop
for whatever reason because you know
you're far away you can make it as noisy
as you want to time i go to bart's house
i always have to i never poop at
any of my friends it's like a nordstrom
bathroom yeah
oh
yeah cause there's not none of that
creepy-ass american way
of having a crack yeah in the public
bath tall ceilings
i like looking out i like looking out
while i'm pooping in the public restroom
just to see who's looking you know
that's so weird yeah i see you too yeah
that's right but then like in
nordstrom's like the blinds are this way
so they can't see him but
i'm always like this i'm looking up
weirdos
yeah yeah you never know people people
be looking you know true
[Music]
you